[Music]
after the fantastic response battle of
gods received across the world one of
the small tidbits of criticism that the
film received was that there wasn't
enough fighting from characters other
than Goku people thought that too much
time had been spent on comedy and well
they just kind of wanted more punching
and boy did they get it with the next
one over the last few months as I'm sure
many of you know I watched and reviewed
pretty much every Dragon Ball film
that's been released to date and through
the ups and downs of this journey
surfing through boring recycled plot
points rushed fight scenes and weird
deus ex machina endings I have now found
myself on the doorstep of my last big
review 2015 Dragon Ball Z resurrection F
one of the strangest paced oddly focused
and wishy-washy films from the modern
Dragon Ball Catalog one that people
really didn't talk about that much
because Dragon Ball super anime began
pretty much right after its release I
have seen this movie but not for years
and I wanted to get a sense of how the
community still felt towards it and so I
asked on Twitter of the three modern
Dragon Ball movies which of them do you
think was the worst by an absolute
landslide with over 18,000 votes cast
resurrection F was the clear majority
holder with 82 percent of the total
votes not a fantastic response from the
fans but let's see how it fares with me
today I am diving in depth reviewing one
of the most criticized Dragon Ball films
from the modern age today I will be
taking a look back at Akira Toriyama's
resurrection and
[Music]
something of interest this is the first
film from toe and Dragonball that had a
script written entirely by Akira
Toriyama someone that has had experience
writing his story from Dragon Ball in
the past with the help of editors for
his manga but this is the first time he
has written a feature-length
self-contained story in script form and
unfortunately I think it shows the film
itself opens eyghon quite strong dealing
specifically with the circumstances that
led to the resurrection of the big app
himself Frieza and the subsequent
consequences of that decision the
dialogue here tries to create a sense of
continuity out of retroactivity similar
to how battle of gods try to establish
beerus as part of Dragon Balls history
this time through characters like sorbet
and his subordinates as they attempt to
locate new Namek and inform Frieza of
the Super Saiyan their reasons for
pursuing Earth's Dragon Balls are
believable and makes sense within the
lore of the show everything that happens
leading up to and including the
resurrection of Frieza makes a
remarkable amount of sense when you
consider that all of this is happening
retro actively without any prior
planning or thought once Frieza is
resurrected the dialogue that he
delivers is absolutely pitch perfect for
his character something to be expected
when you consider this was written by
Akira Toriyama himself he's delightfully
menacing and it's all great until I hear
this line a line that when I hear it now
is the first sign of Akira Toriyama's
inexperience when it comes to
structuring a story for a film
especially
so Goku do you say a diva so none is sad
I need to you can update with oh you
quit or disco some of you might be
thinking that with this line I am taking
issue with freezes ability to get
stronger than Goku in such a short
amount of time I'm really not I'm
actually not bothered by that at all
well I personally take issue with here
is what it sets up and ultimately fails
to deliver upon at this point in the
film the entire story has been about
Frieza and his resurrection the first 18
minutes in fact and what's more is that
when faced with a great photo overcome
and a massive obstacle to defeat Frieza
accepts the call to action the call to
action is something the main character
of a film does before they embark upon a
journey to improve themselves in order
to overcome the goal of the film this
movie's first act is written such that
Frieza is the main character but the
rest isn't
that way at all and here is where the
movie starts to fall apart and
ultimately begin setting up the building
blocks to its own destruction the
following selection of scenes somewhat
acts as a secondary first act for the
rest of the characters Crillon Bulma
piccolo Gohan etc until we finally are
reintroduced to the new main characters
of the movie Goku and Vegeta watching
Goku Vegeta trained under wheeze is
something I enjoy and still do to a
certain extent in this film however as
I've made clear in another video
discussing this very scene with Wiese I
don't buy that Goku is overconfident
remotely and to suggest that him letting
his guard down is an example of that is
flat-out wrong when you look back at
Goku's history in the manga Wiest goes
on to demonstrate Goku's overconfidence
by punching him in the ribs while he's
off guard in a non combative situation
this only serves to prove that he
doesn't have entre instinct which rhesus
training him towards doesn't share
Vegeta's weakness of constantly being on
guard and is just weaker than Wiese all
things that are either good neutral or
we already know it's a pointless
interaction and serves to prove nothing
33 minutes have passed in the film at
this point and there's an hour left this
is when the action begins and doesn't
stop you may have noticed at this point
that there's been an incredibly long set
of first acts and you'd be right this is
where the issue I had with establishing
Frieza as the main character comes
crashing down when a character accepts
the call to action the second act is
typically spend watching that character
overcome obstacles in their way in order
to reach the level they need to be able
to take on the main threat to them at
the end in the case of this film that
thread is Goku infinity war with Thanos
is structured that way typical hero
films are structured that way much like
in Star Wars a new hook but a
resurrection F isn't instead because
accurate Toriyama doesn't one frees it
to be redeemable in the slightest he
skips over all of his struggles and
training and moves straight to act 3
doing the exact same with Goku and
Vegeta but you can jump straight from
Act one to act three so in the middle
instead of putting worthwhile story
progression like 99% of films would he
instead opts to fill it with the most
meaningless fight sequences ever put to
film the Z warriors versus the Frieza
force and first let me say because I
know you're going to have comments
saying at least they gave these
characters for them to do if you give a
character something to do in this
that is not good for the character
unless what they do mean something
within the story if all they do is show
up clean up some grunts and do nothing
else in the context of this movie where
the second act means literally nothing
they become something much more akin to
halftime show entertainment and not the
respect to characters they should be in
other words sometimes being given trash
material to work with is more damaging
than nothing at all now with that said
there are some neat action moments here
and there from them but as I'm sure
you're aware by now I don't care about
flash unless it has substance behind it
if I want to stretch for any utility
this scene offered to the entire story
it's that it provided Goku with a
coordinate to lock onto to join the
action in other words the best these
guys can do is offer a GPS signal for
the main characters the real heroes but
hey at least they're included in the
film right don't make me laugh so with
all that preamble out of the way is time
we dig into the main course the final
act of the film the fight Goku vs Frieza
Galan channel that Super Saiyan glow I
hate so much this is one of my least
enjoyed final fights from the entire
series but that's not to say I don't
enjoy elements of it here and there I
did enjoy the initial flurry Goku and
Frieza experience while shrouded in lice
I thought the plumes of smoke with their
purple and white auras flying upwards
was a striking and effective image and I
thought the most interesting animation
sequences of the film came from some
explosion effects work as Vegeta
defended the onlookers from freezes
deflected energy blasts and the 3d work
that led into the one inch punch later
in the film from beaucoup speaking of
CGI while I don't think this film had
the worst 3d implementation in the
modern movies that distinction goes to
battle of gods
I definitely think resurrection F's
isn't very good either
you can tell they tried to blend 2d
animation and 3d hoping for a more
seamless result and while it's less
jarring overall for sure I can still
tell the instant it shifts from 2d to 3d
and then back to 2d but that's certainly
not the biggest issue this fight has to
contend with personally I'm of the
opinion that the addition of characters
like bears and weaves affect the overall
tension of a fight scene just by
existing on screen during it but if a
fight is structured correctly and the
camera is kept off of them for long
enough then it's possible to achieve
wonderfully engaging action sequences
with ten
and you need look no further than the
Dragon Ball super bro Lee movie from
2018 Weesa isn't seen until the very end
when he is distracting bro Lee and at
that point Gogeta is already their
employee doesn't stand a chance against
him anyway and so while keeping that in
mind remember what I said I loved the
one-inch punch from Goku this is what
the director decided to cut too
immediately after the blow was dealt to
Frieza
and while we're on the topic of poorly
chosen visuals this film's animation
director was tadayoshi Mamoru at his
most unimaginative the beauty of Dragon
Ball and animation in general really is
that you're free to experiment with as
many different angles ideas set pieces
and sequences as your heart desires you
are only limited by your own imagination
this Goku vs Frieza fight has some of
the most boring and uninspired sequences
of action animation I've seen come from
a main fight in the series look at how
many times a character is sent through a
cliff in this movie and that's not even
including all the times a character was
thrown into the water as I've said prior
there are some nice visuals in the form
of animated sequences within the film
most notably from Yuki Hayashi and kuda
watanabe
with even some Yuya takahashi sprinkled
in for good measure but even these
admittedly bright spots are but a
flicker of light amidst a bleak and
dismal backdrop demonstrating an
unimaginably boring storyboard as well
as a color palette that makes Charlie
Chaplin's most early work look like a
laser light rave party and what's more
is I haven't even gotten to what I
dislike most about this movie yet I'm
not sure how controversial this stance
I'm about to make is but here it goes
anyway I think Super Saiyan blue is the
worst transformation unveiling in the
entire series and it completely misses
the point of this narrative tool
entirely transformation is supposed to
or off to I think be used to demonstrate
more than just a physical change in the
character at least when it comes to main
characters anyway the entire point of
all the successful and memorable
transformations from the main cast in
this series has been how their mind and
body has changed as a result of their
transformation with suit
Sam blue it's just a physical change
just thrown into the movie with all the
passion and enthusiasm of a 40-something
working customer service carrying with
it the same lack of emotional way
transformations like pour an oolong
perform oh but they don't count because
they don't look nearly as cool it's not
just about looking cool if that's all
there was to it then transformations
from the likes of czar Bond Frieza and
majin buu would have been just as hype
and emotionally charged as goku vegeta
and Gohan's legendary transformations
were but they weren't super saiyan blue
just shows up and it sucks and I'm not
saying it sucks because I don't think it
looks cool I think it does look cool
something can look cool and still suck
the exact same way something can look
awful but still be great and speaking of
things that are awful I've get to talk
about the most heavily criticized part
of this film oh my god this is happening
again that's right you're not dealing
with one of the biggest criticisms of
the last film was how small Vegeta's
part was to play it compared to Goku's
and I think this film did give Vegeta a
more significant roles so to speak what
I mean by that is his role has much
greater consequence and stakes compared
to the first of these films in battle of
gods he was very much the character that
carried a substantial amount of the
story's comedic moments and supplied
little in the way of action despite
those action tidbits he did provide
being some of the most memorable from
the film but once Goku shows up to face
beerus he becomes very much a background
character the same way others like
Crillon are in resurrection F they
remedy this by making him the fake-out
last stand against Frieza once again not
delivering much in the way of fighting
perhaps even less than in battle of gods
but this time there's much more
emotional weight behind every punch and
it's all the more satisfying for that
given his history with Frieza long ago
and the fact that we now know Goku can
jump in to steal the spotlight like he
did in battle of God
this decision I genuinely have no idea
what they thought the reaction was going
to be it space as if it was trying to be
a mean the part of the film this
scenario is mapped out such that Vegeta
has to take the L and have Goku save the
day
it's a completely aimless and vapid
ending and that's this film really in a
nutshell aimless the film begins with a
series of scenes that act as a perfect
introduction to Frieza as the point of
view main character but then it quickly
switches to Goku Vegeta it sets up what
they have to work on for the movie one
of which being to the detriment of Goku
later in the film Frieza becomes a large
focus of the film once again towards the
middle and the end before switching back
to Goku and Vegeta once again neither of
whom learned anything during its runtime
which leads me to perhaps this movie's
most glaring issue for me personally
once this film ends nothing is different
everything is how it once was
Goku Vegeta are still perfectly fine
alive and training a way to their
heart's content no one died except for
Frieza who was already dead in the first
place you could caught this entire thing
out and all that will be lost is the
knowledge that we scan rewind time which
could be explained in the span of 3
seconds anyway it's the perfect example
of terrible long-term story writing if I
were to place this alongside the other
older Dragon Ball films I would have
said that this is an OK film with some
significant downsides but because this
is a Canon part of an ongoing story I
can't help but feel like I wasted 19
minutes of my life with stuff that
largely irritated me but what do you
think do you think it's fair 82 percent
of Dragon Ball fans think resurrection F
is the weakest film leave a comment down
below don't forget to rate this video
and subscribe if you want to see more
videos like this one as always I've been
totally not mark thank you so much for
watching
[Music]